ce mode économie telle qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui renvoi des conditions de
possibilité qui ne seront pas au
rendez-vous longtemps on est dans un
monde dont la crise climatique est
proprement effrayant la biodiversité est
menacée ou un point tel que la chaîne
alimentaire universelle va s'en trouver
perturbée à terme l'énergie abondante et
abordable connaît aussi ses derniers ces
dernières années des trois dernières
décennies
même chose pour les mêmes faits
longtemps qu'on le dit oui oui mais mais
on en est à chercher du pétrole à 3000
mètres sous les eaux dans de la boue en
alberta je veux dire on est en plus des
on racle les fonds de tiroirs l'avons
l'a6 est l'intérêt cette personne ya 20
ou 30 ans on trouve encore des méthodes
polluantes ans pour arriver à des à
satisfaire une certaine demande mais on
voit bien qu'on arrive si on a un petit
peu le sens de l'histoire là pour
regarder les choses en plus sur le temps
long même à moyen terme
on voit bien content qu'on arrive au
terme de quelques choses le mot économie
ne pourra pas signifier longtemps ce
qu'il signifie aujourd'hui et il faudra
le redéfinir et mon travail est plus un
travail d'anticipation quoi savoir qu'il
y aura un moment où il faudra repenser
l'économie qu'en mettant le une façon
multiple de réfléchir aux relations qui
nous sont potes
[Musique]